here's what would happen if you were  raised by animals  at your first encounter with potential  wild animal parents you'd want to copy  their language and social activities in  order to fit in eventually you'd start  to take on some of their behaviors if  you were adopted by wild animals you'd  likely suffer from severe malnutrition  due to the diet you would eat what they  eat and this could range from eating  fruits to patches of grass or even raw  meat many children have actually been  raised by animals in the wild if humans  discovered you they would try to bring  you back to civilization and adapting to  human life could be very challenging you  could continue to walk around on all  fours and have difficulty digesting  cooked Foods it would be extremely hard  to learn any language or basic hygiene  you would miss your animal family a lot  and potentially develop depression or  anxiety so what if your parent was a  wild animal well